Alhamdulillah. Continuing
[Silence]
in the chapter of truthfulness and truth
authored by Noi. In the fifth narration
of that chapter,
[Silence]
one prophet of the previous nations
went and was preparing his people to
to lead them into battle.
And he said to his men,
[Silence]
And so he said to his men, No man
amongst you
who has married a woman who has not
consummated his marriage with her as of
yet
and is intending to consummate his
marriage with her is to follow me into
this battle.
He said, "Nor any man who has built
any building or houses and has not
completed said houses and finished
raising their roofs,
nor any man who has
livestock
that are pregnant livestock and he is
awaiting them to give birth.
What the point of all of this is is
anyone who has any attachments to this
world that will keep him from giving his
absolute all and utmost in battle
because he is worrying about returning
and he feels he is not ready to be
martyed then this person is not to
follow us. This is a very important
point with respect to soldiers. How many
of his
troops do you think he lost by this? He
gave them an out.
He gave them an out. And he very likely
lost many of his troops who had these
excuses and did not follow him into
battle. So a person may say, well, isn't
the point of an army to have as many
numbers as possible? No. The point of an
army, a military, any group of people
who are undergoing anything of the
commandments of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala, what is
expected is quality, not quantity, not
amount, not numbers. You may walk into
certain or you may see certain
scholars. They have very few students.
Others will have hundreds or thousands.
Yet this is not this is not a gauge for
success. Numbers is not a gauge for
success.
And the companions
understood this. They understood this
lesson in the story of Jal.
[Silence]
that when in the story of Jal he told
his troops
that Allah is going to test you and thin
out the weak amongst you with a river.
So whoever drinks from this river is not
of me is to go back. And whoever does
not drink from this river is to
accompany me further to the front lines
of battle.
And this is what the companions
practiced in their time after the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam's death.
The companions who went for battle
led by
They insisted on their battalions being
purged of anyone who is not a companion.
Anyone who is not a companion is not to
be part of a battalion of the
companions.
They can be their own battalion
of the students, the
but the muajirin and the they wanted to
keep their battalions and their platoon
pure.
And when they had difficulty in
in fighting,
one of the things that they insisted
from
is that they that he separates anyone
who is a non-compion
and that he make their front lines
consistent only of companions.
And when they did that, they were able
to overcome and they were able to
push through the lines of Musam.
And so this is what the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam is telling us here
with regards to this prophet, this
messenger. He said,
He said, "And so when he arrived at the
city that he was to lay siege to,
it was around the time of Ozel or after
Ozel.
And so
he was worried that he would lose this
element of surprise, that he would lose
this element of having the battle. Now
it's nightfall. We'll have to wait until
tomorrow in order to have the battle.
And this will give them an edge. And so
he turned to the son speaking to it and
said, "You have been commanded by Allah
and I also have been commanded by Allah.
Oh Allah, keep the sun up for us."
And so the sun was kept in its position
for the duration of the battle. It did
not set upon them until they had
completed their battle.
He says,
"And so then he gathered the war booty,
the spoils of war, and the spoils of war
were never
allowed to be kept by any prophet or
messenger and his and his army.
always the spoils of war. They would
not be allowed to keep those spoils of
war because this was not the purpose or
the intent of their battle.
However, this nation, the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam as we will hear
at the end of this narration that he
says
that our prophet and his nation
sallallam
is the first nation to be allowed to
keep the spoils of war. We will complete
this narration tomorrow morning.
Inshallah
[Arabic recitation]